PRESENTER: OK.
Good.
I'm going to be very short.
I know you're here
to see Jakob, not me.
But just a couple of
words of introduction.
First, it's my pleasure to
welcome Jakob to Google.
It's not his first time here.
He actually was on the
Google initial advisory board
years and years
ago, and was one of
the original early
consultants at Google.
So he's actually returning.
Jakob is, I think, arguably
the world's foremost expert
on usability right now.
He wrote a book last fall
called "Mobile Usability"
on mobile usability, and I think
there's some copies in the back
that-- if you are
interested-- some are free,
and you can buy them
as well, if you'd like.
Jakob has a Ph.D. from the
Technical Institute of Denmark.
He's worked at
Bellcore, Sun, IBM,
and now is in his own company
with Don Norman-- Nielsen
Norman Group.
One interesting
thing that I found
when I joined Google a few years
ago was-- we were over in 42--
and the design group was
centralized at that point.
And there was a picture
of Jakob on the wall,
kind of in an angelic pose.
And underneath
it, it said, WWJD.
[LAUGHTER]
PRESENTER: And under that, in
case you didn't understand,
what it said was,
What would Jakob do?
So it's kind of a little
bit of an irreverent play
on Jakob's influence at Google
and the field of usability.
So please help me welcome
Jakob to the stage.
[APPLAUSE]
JAKOB NIELSON: Thank you, John.
Thank you, everybody.
Yes, I won't really talk
about mobile usability now,
because I'm sure all you
are working on that anyway.
I'll talk more about the
past and the future, really--
kind of a combined little
set of things there.
Some of the themes
I want to cover
are that we have a lot of things
we know about usability that
is very stable in this
otherwise fast-changing field.
I want to touch a
bit on the question
of the specific
technology and platforms--
whether it matters or
not-- and kind of both
are the answer here.
And then I want to
end with talking
about how we get usability
more widely applied.
Before I do that, I was
just going to show you
a little video clip
of one of-- you
know, we do a lot
of user testing,
as you do as well--
Is to show you
a video clip of
one of the studies.
And this is a study--
was done, actually,
in London, as it turns out.
But we did it in a
hotel, because we
didn't have a lab there.
So as you may know,
in hotels, when
you want to get
onto the internet,
they first show their
own hotel screen,
and then you kind of
click through that,
and then you get online.
Right?
And for everybody
in this room, that's
not anything you consider
to be a usability problem
But we had this
user-- and I'm going
to show you what happened
when he was trying
to get onto the-- so he's
just trying to get online,
basically-- that's the problem.
So all of your work
is for nothing,
because you can't get to Google.
And the reason I'm showing
you this is that it really-- I
think this showcases,
in many ways,
the design challenge we're
facing-- that we have
a lot of users whose
mental model of computers
and the internet is like there's
no distinction between what's
a browser, or what's a web
site, what's an operating
system, what's this
and that and the other.
For all the people
in this room, we
have those very
clear distinctions.
And that helps us then
understand all the fancy stuff.
But this guy couldn't even
get onto the internet, really.
He couldn't get to Google.
He didn't distinguish
between what's
a browser, what's a
Google, what's a website.
Our moderator who was
running this study
was kind of violating,
a little bit, some
of the rules for
doing user testing,
because he was helping him here.
But the reason for that was
that we were not interested here
in studying how he gets online.
We're interested in studying how
he would use various websites.
We had to get him to
those websites, which
is why you should
try to help them.
Well, maybe if you use another
browser, it'll be easier.
No, that was not the
problem, actually.
So I think we have still a
lot of things in usability.
And that's just
going to-- again,
for a little bit of history--
show some of the cases
where I have taken
big companies to task.
Because, of course, small
companies make design mistakes
as well, but the big ones
are the ones that are worth
talking about.
Flash-- 99% bad.
I mean, that was just
really-- at that time--
a great assault on usability.
WAP was the early way
of doing mobile devices.
And I think WAP
is a great example
of that the technology
actually does matter.
Because it's not just
that it was mobile way
of getting onto the internet.
It was such a bad way of
getting on to the internet
that it was said it didn't work.
We did a big study
of this in 2000.
And usually in my company,
when we do a study,
we publish a big report with
guidelines and how we recommend
you should do design.
But in that case,
there was only, really,
one guideline, which
was, don't do it.
Because WAP was so bad.
Right?
PDF online.
So the one I had here,
the search engines.
This is actually not a complaint
about Google being bad.
It's a complaint about
Google being too good.
The others, I complained
about the bad design.
This is actually a
complaint about good design,
because I think Google has
been so good that it has kind
of almost taken over
the internet more
than I would like to see.
But I can't really ask
you to do worse work.
So I don't really
know how to handle
that problem, other than, ask
other people to do better work,
I guess.
Amazon's Kindle-- that's
another good example
that the details really matter.
Because their first
attempt at doing
a tablet was really terrible.
And we did user testing
on this, and just
with a handful of people.
And it's a great example of why
you can do it with few people,
and you will really learn.
Because we had-- just
with those few people,
it was clear that it was
insufferable to get anything
done on-- I would say-- on
the 2011 model of the tablet.
Now, last year's model
is already much better.
Another example of that, by
the way, was the WAP study.
Because I believe we had about
10 users or so in that study.
And after we
published the findings
to the telecoms industry--
the entire telephony industry
was just a huge industry,
particularly back then.
Kind of rejected our findings.
Said, well, you only tested
it with so few people,
and they only had their
phones for a week.
And it's kind of like,
well, if after a week
you still can't figure out
how to get tonight's weather
forecast, and we asked people,
would you like to use it,
and they say no,
it's kind of like--
[LAUGHTER]
JAKOB NIELSON: This is
not a small finding,
in which case, for sure, if it
had been a little issue, then
it wouldn't have been
a big enough study
to determine the
big and small issue.
But for a big issue, for sure.
The latest example is Windows 8.
And what I wrote
about Windows 8,
it should be called
Microsoft Window--
[LAUGHTER]
JAKOB NIELSON: In the singular.
Because they abandoned
multi-windowing,
which is their
trademark, really.
And that's another example
where it's-- reportedly,
they're now going to
kind of scale back,
and do it either right--
or at least better--
the second time around.
But for a lot of
these cases, a lot
of these kind of
really big failures
were things that
could have been found
with relatively small studies.
I mean, our studies
are not big studies.
We don't have the budget of
Microsoft Usability department,
or Amazon Design Group, or
anything of that nature.
And we find, with
very small studies,
that these are failed products.
So I do think that
these big companies need
to get better-- except maybe
Google needs to get worse.
I don't know.
But because I have been
doing these things,
it's been somewhat
controversial over the years.
And so I do see things like this
from time to time getting out
there.
This one I kind of like better.
This is when I did this
talk with Don Norman.
And it's like-- feel like
the rebel alliance, you know,
trying to make things
better for the people.
But one of the big
things that people
say against all of this work
that I'm talking about here
is that, when we
have our usability
findings and these guidelines
and recommendations,
it constrains their
creative freedom.
So is it true that designers
are sort of suffering
under these nasty
usability people?
And I would say no.
And I'll give you a few
different arguments for that.
And so my first one,
I'll take an analogy
from the field of music.
And I'll do this little
participatory exercise here.
So I'm going to play for
you two pieces of music.
So this one piece of
music, but performed twice.
And it's by two
different opera singers.
So they're both going to
sing the same little piece
of an opera, and your
job is to identify
which of these two opera singers
is Luciano Pavarotti-- you
know, this rather fat, very
famous opera singer, Pavarotti.
So which of these two people--
the first or the second--
they'll sing same
thing-- who is Pavarotti?
[OPERA SINGING]
JAKOB NIELSON: OK.
Exact same thing, second singer.
[OPERA SINGING]
JAKOB NIELSON: OK.
So who thinks that
number one was Pavarotti?
We have 5% of the audience.
Who thinks number
two was Pavarotti?
And we have 80% of the audience.
And the last 15%
have no opinion.
OK, so the majority
was right, which
means that you guys
are all big opera fans.
Well done.
But it's clear--
in this example,
it's clear there
there's a difference.
And the first guy was
a great singer, too.
But there's still a difference
between the singers.
And this is a very
constrained design problem,
to create this
operatic performance,
because every single
note they're singing
was written more
than 100 years ago.
Every word they're singing was
written more than 100 years
ago.
And yet, there's
plenty of creativity
left in the performance.
And design is not nearly
that constrained, you know.
And what we're doing
in usability is,
we're documenting the
facts of the world, which
is how things really work.
And so as an example--
another example--
let's see if I have a pen here.
I have a pen.
So here I have a pen.
And since I'm actually
giving a lecture now,
I don't really need a pen.
So therefore, I'm just
going to leave my pen here.
You see the pen, right?
I'm going to leave it there.
And maybe later I think,
maybe I do need my pen anyway.
So I'll go, I'll get my pen.
And do you remember
where to leave my pen?
I left it here.
I'd swear it.
So this is bad.
I leave my pen here.
This is where I want my pen.
Now I'm very annoyed
with Sir Isaac Newton.
Why did Newton come up with
this stupid law of gravity
that causes my pen to
not be where I want it?
Well, that's clearly
the wrong reaction.
It's not Newton's fault that
things fall to the ground.
It's not my fault
that people have
trouble using certain websites.
It's because that's the
way human people are.
And so, in my view,
usability constrains design
in one way, which
is that it reveals
the facts of the world, which
is the fact of the users.
And users are very
different than you guys.
Users are like the first
guy we saw in the video.
And that's how it is.
And they are like
that whether or not
we'd show the video clip.
They are like that anyway.
And you've got to design for
the way people actually are.
And so that's really what I'm
trying to kind of get through
is those issues.
And we have a lot of
things we have learned
over the years about usability.
There's also things that
are not unchangeable facts.
So let me show another
example to demonstrate that.
So what am I doing now?
Anybody knows what
I'm doing now?
AUDIENCE: Holding
a pine cone up.
JAKOB NIELSON: You're
being very literal here.
[LAUGHTER]
JAKOB NIELSON: I'm guarding
against evil spirits.
If you've ever been
to the British Museum,
you will have seen this.
This is the gesture for
guarding against evil spirits.
But you don't have to
go to British Museum,
you can also go to
Louvre in Paris,
and you'll see there as well.
There's in fact endless
of these monuments that
show this guarding
against evil spirits.
When you hold up like this, it's
guarding against evil spirits.
So it was universally
accepted-- at least in Syria
3,000 years ago.
And today, I think
nobody knew, right?
So in that sense, that's
kind of like, well,
can we use this icon?
I mean-- well, if it's
universally known,
yes, I can use the pine cone
gesture to guard against--
to make you feel I'm guarding
you against evil spirits.
On the other hand,
there's no inherent reason
why that should be so.
That can easily
change over time.
And a great example of
that in the web world
is whether blue
indicates click-ability.
There's no real inherent reason
blue should mean click here.
For a long time it
did, because that
was the way all websites worked.
And today, it's one of the ways.
It's probably still-- marginally
speaking-- the best way.
But there's not a big thing
there specifically in blue.
On the other hand, a
lot of other things
are pretty long
lasting and universal.
So for example, if
you have a big head,
you're probably important guy.
[LAUGHTER]
JAKOB NIELSON: Right?
And that's many
thousand years ago,
and we can still see
the same thing today.
Or you want to give people
an idea of what's ahead,
which we sometimes call
information send up,
before people go there.
So this is a photo from
the Las Vegas airport.
It's very useful,
very good usability
to have things like that.
And those are more universal.
Or that complexity is inherently
more difficult to use.
So I have both these
two kitchen timers,
but the one with the big numbers
that can read without glasses,
and it's easier to
set it-- and how often
do you really need to
keep track of like three
different roasts
at the same time?
It's not nearly
as useful, right?
So I think a lot of these things
we have found over the years
really do still matter.
Another example is
that a lot of people
have been kind of rejecting this
because of banner blindness,
but which I keep finding
it again and again.
So to the right
are some examples
of some eye tracking studies.
And I put in these little boxes
indicating where the ads are,
and you see no fixations there.
To the left, on
the other hand, I
have an example from one of
the first studies we did.
Enough-- is it
annoying enough yet?
Had a little running car there.
So in that study,
we asked people
to find out about delivery
information on this flowers
website.
And nobody could find.
And this thing-- this
blinking delivery truck--
was on the screen at all times,
and people couldn't find it.
And it's because if it looks
like-- it was not an ad.
It was, in fact, important
delivery information.
But if it looks like an
ad, it'll be tuned out.
And this is just
a learned behavior
that keeps being like that.
I'll show you another example,
because it's really nice.
We did a few years ago a
study on the Ask website.
How can you not notice that?
[LAUGHTER]
JAKOB NIELSON: Big rat right in
the middle of the page, right?
But that's how it is.
And I can spend another
five hours showing you
more video clips of
the same phenomenon.
But they really are true.
And so what I want to
talk about-- so therefore,
that's why a lot of
the technology issues
don't matter as
much as we think.
I think there's a lot
of tendency in our field
to believe that because we
moved to a new platform,
all the rules are different.
Because we have, let's
say, faster bandwidth.
Something that-- things changed.
So some things do change.
That's very true.
But a lot of them don't.
And we are too enamored, I
believe, with technology,
as opposed to these kind of
really basic human factors
phenomena.
So I'm going to show
you an example of that
from one of my own
very early work,
just to show you how I
make bad mistakes as well.
So this is a study
I did in 1984.
And the problem is, if
you have more information
than you can fit
in the screen, how
do you do what-- that's a very--
how do you deal with that?
And so there are two
ways of dealing with it.
So if I'm going to, let's say,
want to watch-- view line K,
right?
Is that up or down?
Right?
So it could be I move
the information up.
So that was, mental model is Up.
It could also be that I
move my view port down,
and now K is visible.
So those are two
different ways of thinking
about the same problem.
So at the time--
in '84-- I'd been
to some usability conferences.
And there was some
research done at IBM.
And at IBM at the time, they
had these full screen text
only terminals--
the-- whatever they're
called-- 3270 terminals.
And they had done
a study showing
that if people had the mental
model, in this case, Down, then
they will perform a little
bit better than if they
had the mental model Up.
So you just change what
you call the commands.
I mean, the same thing
will actually happen,
but if you change what
you call the commands,
people will be a little
bit faster if they think
of it being a Down command
to display the line K.
And of course, they
test display the line A
as well, and all that.
And I had seen these
early computers
that had come out at the
time, like Macintosh and stuff
like that-- really early
revolutionary graphical user
interfaces-- and so I
went to the university.
I was too poor to
actually buy a Macintosh.
They were expensive at the time.
So I didn't have one.
But I had seen the demos.
And in demos, it
was very clear to me
that you could see the graphical
user interface-- you could
really see the text move
up in a more smooth manner
then you could see in those
full screen terminals.
So to me, it very much felt
like it was an Up command
to move the K up
to become visible,
because you could
see it move up.
So we actually did get hold
of a graphical computer
at university, and we
implemented this thing,
and did the study.
And I really expected that now I
would prove that graphical user
interfaces required the opposite
mental model of text-based user
interfaces, because clearly
in text it was Down.
Text only screens were Down,
and in graphical user interfaces
it was Up.
Our study came out the
same as the IBM study.
Down was a superior
mental model.
I mean, not by a
lot, but by a little.
And the reason was because the
difference between up and down
here was not the
difference between text
only versus graphical screen.
The difference was between you
moving something and seeing
it being moved.
When I just saw
the demo-- I didn't
have the computer myself.
And when I saw the demo,
the text was clearly moving.
But when I was there, I was
clearly moving-- or the user
was there-- they were
clearly moving towards K.
I mean, their thinking was, I
want to move down the document.
And that became
the dominant factor
in which of these two ways
of thinking about the problem
are superior.
And so I point this
out because I'm
kind of arguing against us being
too enamored of technology,
while admitting
in this example I
was too enamored of technology.
Because I thought
that the difference
in the type of display we were
using would make a difference.
And in fact, it was a
different user's task
that was making the difference.
And of course today,
we do have, actually,
an interesting
difference, because now we
have another way of
moving information, which
is with a gesture.
And so when you're
moving the gesture,
then actually moving
to see K actually
does feel like an Up movement.
That's because now I'm
actually moving the text.
Before, I was
manipulating the window.
So again, it's a
difference in the task
that makes the difference.
And I think that's important
for us to keep remembering.
Now, after this long argument
about how technology doesn't
matter, it actually does matter.
Because even though I think the
big principles are definitely
the same, a lot of the smaller
details are very different.
And the details matter so
immensely to usability.
It's like people can have a
lot of really big picture ideas
that they do really right,
and if people can't figure out
where to click, the entire
thing is for nothing.
Right?
And we've seen a lot
of examples of this.
One of the most recent ones
to come out was, I think,
Facebook's home
thing for Android,
which reportedly was a big
failure, because it didn't
design, really, for
Android's special features.
But that is history
repeating itself,
because the exact same thing
has happened many times
over with, for example,
people porting software
from Windows to the
Mac-- just like earlier
versions of Microsoft Word and
things like that, that were not
really native to
that environment.
Or when Windows was young,
people porting things from DOS
to Windows, and it wasn't
a graphical user interface.
So it's really just
another example
of the same point,
which is, have
a design for the
characteristics of the device.
And as the devices--
particularly
the more primitive or simplistic
they are, the more important
it becomes to really
fit with them.
If you have a very
broad, general purpose,
like powerful, it's
maybe a little bit less
so important to
exactly fit it right.
So if you have a really
big, huge computer screen,
and a very powerful
computer, you
can suffer a little bit more
that it's not 100% right.
And if you have a
small phone, it's
more important that
it's exactly right.
And so there's a lot
of discussion today
about things like
responsive designs
and so forth-- about how you
can makes things adapt and fit
to the different environments,
different screen sizes,
and so forth.
And on the one hand,
it's very appealing,
because you obviously want to
design once and run everywhere.
But I remember once
we had this slogan,
code once and run everywhere.
And it really was like, code
once and run everywhere,
but test everywhere as well.
Because it still broke
in half the cases.
And that's the same here.
If you're trying
to make a design,
it's like reform flows
itself, and you're
using it under
different circumstances,
then you do need some different
prioritization of features.
Maybe certain things
should not be visible
initially, and so forth.
So I'm going to show you
another example of this--
of how the details matter.
And this goes back to
this WAP study from 2000.
So again, looking at it.
So this was considered to
be an advanced mobile phone
at the time.
And you can see here that if
we wanted to see the news,
first we get a News screen up.
Then the upper left and upper
right is, we get a News menu.
Then we select News.
Lower left is the menu
of news headlines.
We select one of
these headlines--
let's say "Railtrack
says Hatfield line not
in good state."
So then we get an
article, lower right.
What exactly happened is
that over four screens
we've gotten two
lines of actual news,
because they keep repeating
the same things over
and over again.
So for example, when we go
from lower left to lower right,
they repeat that headline
that we just clicked on.
Now, in traditional
design guidelines
for things like
websites and so forth,
for hypertext
navigation, all that,
the traditional guideline
is to actually confirm
the user's location.
Give them some
navigational situations,
and confirm from what they just
did, they know where they are.
Also, things like "eXcite Latest
News"-- the top line-- as well,
is another example of
navigational feedback
or confirmation.
So in that sense, they are
following one of the guidelines
that in 2000 we would
have had for doing
a website for a
desktop computer.
But for this small
display, those guidelines
should actually
not be followed--
you should follow other
guidelines instead that says,
really maximize
amount of content
you're giving to people when
you have that small a screen.
And interestingly
enough, it may be
that these type of findings
we had back from that study
are relevant again now
with design for watches,
because smaller screens
are getting popular again.
But my main point,
anyway, is you really
have to optimize for the device,
the smaller device we get.
So I want to talk now about
how to broaden this out
to more people and
more companies.
And of course, it's nice that
big companies like Google
has a great user research and
great designers and everything.
But we need more
companies to do it.
We need all 300 million websites
to do well in all of that.
So again, I want to reach
back through history
and give you an example here.
So this is from 1628.
So if you go to Stockholm
in Sweden today,
you will see this ship
here-- the museum.
It's an old warship.
And it was built in 1628.
So at the time, Sweden
was at war with Poland,
and the King decided they had
to have a really big warship
to fight the Poles,
and so they built
this ship that was the biggest
warship they ever built.
And when it had been
built, it was still
sitting at the harbor--
hadn't sailed yet.
But the captain said, well,
before we launch this ship,
we should do a stability
test on the ship.
So you've got all
these sailors on deck,
and you had them
run back and forth.
So they run to the one side
of the deck, and all of them
run to the other
side of the deck.
And they run back and forth.
So as these guys
run back and forth,
the ship sort of starts
leaning more and more--
tilts and tilts and tilts.
And so at this point of time
during the stability test,
the admiral of the Swedish
fleet comes down to the harbor
and sees what they're
doing, and he orders
the captain, stop
that test-- we're
going to launch this ship now.
So they set sail, they launched
the ship, they sail out.
And while they're in the middle
of the harbor, a gust of wind
comes and blows over the ship.
It keels over, it sinks.
And it sank in the middle
of Stockholm harbor,
which is why they recovered
it hundreds of years later,
and it's a museum now.
But it never made
out of the harbor.
It was that unstable a ship.
And so this story actually
proved two things.
The first, of course,
is that Star Trek
was right-- captains are
smarter than admirals.
[LAUGHTER]
JAKOB NIELSON: But the second
thing-- more to our point--
is that, test before you
launch, or your ship will sink.
And so it's just
proven hundreds of-- I
mean, every time, basically.
You've got to do it
before you launch.
I saw a nice t-shirt by some
guys in Italy that says,
test it, or they will detest it.
It sounds better in Italian.
But that's the basic point.
So we want to do these
very early simple studies.
And here's an example
of a study that-- one
of my early studies of
some early intranet icons,
through testing with
just four users.
And the first one was intended
to be a bulletin board
symbolizing what's new.
And what the users said was--
bulletin board, bulletin board,
bulletin board, laundry.
Now, when you have one
of four users telling you
that your icon is completely
mistaken, that's 25% percent.
But it's not really a
statistically reliable number
there.
So what are you going
to do about that?
And so this is where the
expertise comes into play.
You interpret this
data, and you say,
well, it's probably not
going to actually impact,
when we have people
used to this,
that they're going to think it's
laundry, so we keep the icon.
But in further research,
we keep in mind
if it's going to
cause any issues.
And it never did.
So that was the
correct decision.
The next icon--
the middle icon--
was intended to
mean World Wide Web.
This was so new at
the time, and it's
represented in the interface.
So what did people say?
Networking on a world
scale-- that's close enough,
Map/location/global, the
dimensions of the planet--
really completely off
the wall, and networking
around the world,
also pretty close.
Well, so here again we have just
a few people getting it wrong.
It's really the same
as for the first icon,
statistically speaking.
But here my decision
was, there's
something wrong with this icon.
And the reason is,
I can refer back
to some usability principles,
which in this case
is a mismatch in dimensionality.
The globe is a
three-dimensional object,
and the network map is
a two-dimensional map,
and that's a mismatch.
And that's what causes
people to not understand--
the two things don't
feel connected.
So we replaced the 3D
globe with a flat map--
as you can see, the final
icon-- and that worked well.
So this is kind of why, if
you're going to do these kind
of very small end tests,
you cannot really realign
on a statistic.
You have to rely
on interpretations.
So why is it OK to rely
on interpretations?
Because we do know
things about usability.
This doesn't mean that these
interpretations are always
100% accurate.
But it does mean that they
are likely to be correct.
And it's going to be
easier to make a decision
and proceed on your project,
while keeping in mind--
like with this first icon--
that just maybe you're wrong,
and you may have to
revisit your position.
Because remember that no
decision is also a decision.
And if you don't
act on the data,
then you are much
more likely to be
wrong than if you let
yourself be guided
by just a little bit of data.
So the probability of
making the right decision
actually goes up
dramatically with even
a tiny, tiny amount of data.
So what we want to do is to want
to expand the use of these user
research usability
methods around the world.
And I have the little--
cited complex chart
here to indicate this.
There are two ways,
really, how you
can do better in
terms of usability.
And on the x-axis is better
methodologies-- so doing
what I and many other
people recommend.
And on the y-axis, we have you
could have better management
support.
You could have it more
institutionalized, more
a part of the official
way the company is run.
So there's two kind of-- there's
a pragmatic how you do it,
and then there's kind of on
how it's organizationally
Instituted and supported.
So there are two different
ways you can worry about.
And these bubbles
here indicate--
we did a survey among people
participating in an event
that we run called
Usability Week.
So 244 people positioned
their company on these scales.
And in fact, there's quite
a lot of people from Google
who go to this event.
So probably some
of them are you.
But of course, it's anonymous.
So I can't say where
Google is in the map
according to the
Googlers themselves.
But you can think about that.
That's your little
take-home exercise.
But what I want to point out is
that-- so the size of bubbles
indicates how many people
positioned their company
at that spot in the diagram.
And what we really
want to point out
is how the vast majority of
companies are in the red zone.
So they don't do really quite
the recommended methodologies,
and don't have that much
management support for it
either.
And this is, of course,
a biased sample,
because these are people who
come to usability conference.
So if we think about all
companies in the world,
they would probably
be much worse off.
But this is why we are still
in the early stages of really
making design driven
by user needs.
So there are some companies
up in the green area
that do most-- or
maybe even everything,
for a very few up at the number
eight-- do everything right.
But another thing that's
interesting about this chart
is, we don't have so many people
out in the other corners--
the upper left and
lower right corner.
We have a pretty high
correlation between these two
dimensions of two
different things you
can do, so that every day,
as I'm doing methodology
work and the management
support, and how much
it's part of the company
culture and institutionalized,
these two things tend
to go quite together.
And that's interesting,
because they
are two different strategies
for how to get better design.
And different people have
different opinions about it.
So actually, in the
Nielsen Norman Group,
I have been the one advocating
the methodology approach.
Let's do it.
And my colleague Don Norman
has been advocating more
the management support role--
let's convince management
to do better.
And the truth is, really,
that both of us are right.
In this instance you need both.
Because these things
tend to be quite-- as
you can see from the
data-- quite correlated
among companies.
But if you think
about this point
that almost everybody--
even among the biased sample
of companies that do care
enough about usability
to send people to usability
conference-- even there,
most companies are
in the red zone.
So we're still in
the early stages
of really getting technology
to work for people.
I mean, even just
before we did this talk,
I had trouble getting
the projector set up.
And thanks to the good A-V
staff here, we've made it work.
But it's amazing that
still-- to this day--
we have to struggle of just
projecting a simple slide show.
And that's because
technology companies still
care too much about, let's
put on some new feature,
as opposed to make
the old feature work.
I think we need more attention
just to that simple quality
assurance, really.
OK.
So to conclude here, some of the
big challenges for usability.
I think we need to have much
more focus on productivity
growth for knowledge workers.
And so much of
what we hear today
is more about the fun or
playful side of computers, which
is also very
important, admittedly.
But we do live in a
knowledge economy.
And supporting, essentially,
our type of work,
but many other types
of work as well.
Collaborative
work, all this kind
of more information
processing work.
We don't really have, I
think, a good enough grasp.
And that is one
of the big reasons
that growth in the economy
is really slowing down
in all the advanced
countries is,
we know how to make agriculture
more productive for sure.
We know how to make industrial
manufacturing more productive.
Those two segments of industry
are both doing extremely well
at being more and more
productive every year.
But our share of the economy,
which is much the biggest
these days, we don't know how
to make us much more productive.
And one of the
reasons we don't know
is that it's not
worked on very much.
So a project we did recently
was about social networking
in the enterprise-- social
networking and intranets.
And we studied a lot
of different companies
who are doing these
type of things.
And the common feedback
we asked about-- so
how do you make sure the
ROI-- the return on investment
of your investment in
adding these features
to your internal
computer system?
People said, well, it's
obvious we should have that.
Just like email-- it's
obvious we should have it.
Well, obvious is
not good enough.
Because it's
actually not obvious.
There's so many-- we have had
so many other examples of things
that sounded good
but were not good,
or were done in a
sub-optimal manner.
That I feel that
that's the same here.
That if we really found
better ways of measuring which
type of computer interfaces
really make people, let's
say, better at problem
solving, more creative,
more able to get their work done
in a more high value fashion,
it would vastly
increase our growth
of the economy-- our
contribution to the economy.
That's just one of the
really biggest things.
Another one is the health risks
of information technology,
where I particularly want to
point out the problem of driver
distraction, which is a
huge killer of people.
So it's possible that the real
answers with driver distraction
is the driver-less car.
So maybe you guys
are on to that.
But truthfully,
even if that works--
and it would be at least 10
years before everybody has one,
that's for sure.
So let's just look at
the 10-year perspective.
So over the next 10 years,
about two million people
will be killed by driver
distraction worldwide.
So one more thing
about this is--
people who work on
Android here, you're
going to be responsible for
about one million people being
killed over the next 10 years.
I mean, not personally
responsible,
but I mean, because they
use it wrong, and so forth.
And so if we can work on
driver distraction, and really
try-- not even
solve the problem,
but just reduce the problem.
So if we could reduce driver
distraction to the point
where we could cut these
deaths in half, that way
we could save a million
people from being
killed over the next 10 years.
It may be not as good as
curing cancer, but it's almost.
It's a really
major thing that we
could do if we could really
address this problem some more.
And there used to be this issue
about couch potatoes-- people
sitting and watching
television and getting sick.
And now we're
probably just going
to have iPad potatoes instead.
So same type of problem again.
There's also other issues that
are maybe not as well known.
So the internet has
really been pushing
a much more shallow
approach to information--
as we know-- this kind of in,
out, and just kind of click
quickly on things, and all that.
Which is what information
forwarding theory predicts.
Because the easier
it is to move around,
the more people
will move around.
And they will move
around information.
So they don't sit and
immerse themselves deeply.
I just wrote a new book--
I can't help myself.
But the truth is
that a lot of people
don't read books anymore.
They just look at--
[SNAP] like this--
a web page about the stuff.
And you don't really learn
as much from a web page
as you do from, let's
say, reading a book.
So we need to do something
to overcome this problem,
and also look at what effect
does this have for, let's say,
the school system or
for children's learning.
But just for our-- adult
people's-- our learning,
our ability to
understand new things.
It's a very shallow information
environment on the web,
unfortunately.
My final point is about
old users or seniors.
So as we all know.
we have a problem with
the aging society,
in terms of things like Social
Security, because those pension
schemes were
introduced when there
was a lot of young
people available to pay
for each old person
to be retired.
And nowadays, two things happen.
First of all,
people live longer,
which is, generally
speaking, good.
And secondly, lower
birth rate means
we have fewer younger people.
So now there's
fewer young people
to pay for each old
person to be retired.
So Social Security is
going bankrupt soon.
We all know that.
But that's only one thing.
There's also the
problem of-- going back
to the issue of
productivity, we know
that productivity is
declining as people age,
in terms of some of the more raw
measures of things you can do,
like how fast you can get
various different things done.
And so the hope is that,
in return for that,
old people are hopefully more
knowledgeable, and so forth.
That goes to my first point.
We don't really know yet how
to really do well on that.
But in any case, we
are an aging society.
We are going to have more
and more old people around.
And so we need to
really focus also
on supporting old people
in use of computers.
And that's another thing
that's being quite ignored,
and most companies are much
more interested in chasing
after teenagers than
chasing after grannies.
I'm going to show
you-- this is a study
that we just
announced, actually,
today-- so this is
news, the data we did.
We did a little study
where we compared seniors
versus middle aged
people, I guess,
using a variety of websites.
And you can see here--
the usability matrix here.
Basically, seniors have
lower success rate.
They're slower--
they're 43% slower
at doing the same things.
They make more errors.
And not surprisingly
they, therefore,
don't like these
websites as much.
So we put all that
together, right?
And we can see that we really
have a significant problem
if we want to empower
this group of users,
and empower in so many ways.
It could be to stay in
the workforce longer
to solve some of our
problems in the economy.
Or it could be more on
a personal fulfillment
based thing.
I mean, people
are living longer,
so they should stay
active longer as well.
So all these different ways
we need to really work harder
on making websites
and other technology
more usable for seniors.
I'm going to end with just
a one video clip of one
of the people in
our seniors study.
[LAUGHTER]
JAKOB NIELSON: So yeah-- that's
how real people are, right?
And so I show this video
clip for two reasons.
One is, I think his
last reaction is,
that's the business rationale
for doing usability, right?
Because delete if they
can't use your site.
But the other was maybe the
more human and humane issue.
That we really do
need to support
a broader set of people.
And if we do that-- we all
talk about this great future
of computers and how
great technology can be.
But it only really
will be great if we
can support all
of these peoples.
And we can.
We just have to work on it.
So thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
PRESENTER: All right.
I think we have about 10
minutes for questions.
So we have a mic here.
And we also have a Dory that
you can post a question to.
And let's take one from the Dory
before we get somebody here.
You've talked about
this first one.
How do you think about
designing across devices,
such as mobile, tablet, laptop,
glass, driver-less cars,
consistency versus
unique tailored features?
JAKOB NIELSON: I
think it is a paradox.
Because, as I said in my talk,
it's like on the one end,
technology does not matter,
and on the other hand, it does.
So I think you first
have to find out
what are the core
user needs, and try
to make those consistent
across the devices.
But then you have to,
on the other hand,
adapt to the circumstances
of the specific platform.
Because if you don't do that--
if it just kind of grates
on people as they are
using it on that platform--
they will just
not want to do it.
On the other hand,
we already have
more of a trans-media
environment,
where people do move between
devices during the day.
And if they can't keep their
expectations constant--
so it's more like the
deeper expectations should
be kept constant, but the
more surface manifestations
should be adapted to the device.
PRESENTER: All right.
Next one-- and if anybody
has a question here,
we've got a mic there.
But have you run any
voice-related studies?
If so, what are the primary
insights that you've gained?
JAKOB NIELSON:
Well, I'd say this
is so long ago that I'm not
sure how much it translates.
But I used to work
at the phone company,
and we did some things
that were only voice.
But it really is so long ago
that I can't really-- I think
the main problem, I
think, with voice-- well,
the other thing we've
done, of course,
is a lot of accessibility
studies with blind people,
and that is voice only as well.
And I think the
main thing I want
to say about that is,
the problem with voice
is that it's one dimensional.
It kind of has low persistence.
So as soon as the word
is uttered, it's gone.
So memory load is a much
harder problem in anything
that's an audio interface.
And so that's-- again, it
goes back to this thing about
you've got to design
for the device.
In this case, design to really
try to minimize memory load.
But also, the word order
becomes more important.
The thing that people
should remember the most
should be said last, which
is more important in voice
than with it on the screen,
where they can kind of glance
over everything almost equally.
PRESENTER: Let's go live.
AUDIENCE: So there's been a
movement, especially with touch
devices, away from
words and menus,
and more toward
sometimes features
that need to be-- they're not
that obviously discoverable,
and you kind of discover them
by touching sort of randomly
and playing around.
Do you have any advice on how
to teach people that are not
normally familiar with
touchscreen devices
how to discover these
types of features?
JAKOB NIELSON: Yeah.
First of all, I would
actually recommend
against that, because I
think that discoverability
is an inherent problem.
And I think it's better to
make things visually apparent,
hoping people will
discover them.
Because most people don't
tend to explore so much.
Little children do that a lot.
They really like to
poke around everywhere.
So we found and
studied some kids
that they actually prefer this
kind of mine sweeping thing--
move my hand around and touch
things and see if it-- not
blows up, but if things happen.
Right?
So that's a nice kind of
games-like environment.
But for grown-up
users, they tend
to be so focused on
the thing that they
know that they don't
explore other places.
I mean, you can do things
like having little demo mode
or reveal modes, and
some form of animations.
But I think that's also
almost like Band-Aid type
of solutions.
So I think anything
that's a core feature,
I really would encourage
to still emphasize
discoverability.
Because the majority
of people don't like
to spend their time
playing with computers.
See, we do.
This is, again, about how we
are different than the majority
of people.
So the majority of people don't
spend so much time exploring,
and therefore, they often will
never explore these features.
And actually almost
worse, sometimes they
may discover them by mistake,
not knowing what they've done.
This is called
accidental activation,
which is a big problem
in touchscreens--
that you touch
something by mistake.
And if you didn't
know what you touched,
it kind of is almost
like it literally
is blowing up under you.
So that's another kind
of downside of that.
So yeah.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
PRESENTER: Let's have another
question live, please.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm wondering, how do you
think about change and change
aversion?
Like when people are
iterating on interfaces
or rolling out new
versions of a service?
That's always a big
topic internally.
JAKOB NIELSON: Yeah.
Oh, but I think
the first thing is
to recognize that it is real.
And so if you roll
out something,
you get a lot of
nasty email, it's
not because you did a bad job.
It's because users
just don't like change.
So that's the first And
just kind of steel yourself.
I wouldn't say ignore that.
But don't take it so seriously.
There's a lot of criticism just
when something new comes out.
But that said, it is real.
And therefore, you shouldn't
roll new things out just
to be new.
And I think there's a lot
of problems with the people
who work on a design
project, to feel
that it needs a kind
of fresh approach.
Because you sit staring
at this screen all day,
whereas the users don't.
Or even if they do, they
don't care about it,
so they don't absorb
as much about it.
So that would be my kind
of-- another recommendation
is to kind of be
conservative, and don't
change unless it really
is a major step up.
Because if it's a small step,
it's probably not worth it.
Because you are going to
aggravate a lot of people.
So those would be my main
recommendations there.
But for sure, we want
to do new things, right?
So you want to have
new design as well.
But only when it's big news.
AUDIENCE: As a
researcher, how do you
distinguish when you're getting
feedback between something--
how can you tell if it is
change aversion, versus this
is actually a step backwards?
JAKOB NIELSON: True, true, true.
I mean, you probably
can't, really,
other than you have to expect
that there's some change
aversion.
So therefore, if people
just say, I don't like it,
then it's likely to be that
it's just because it's different
one to what they already know.
On the other hand, if they have
difficulty using it, well, then
you have to-- of course,
there's a possibility
that it's just because
they're very used
to doing things in one way.
And that's when you may have
to do a longitudinal study,
and you may have
to actually hire
people for a week or something,
that can just torture them
until they get over that.
And then, if you still
have the problem, well,
then it really is bad.
On the other hand, if
after a day or two,
people are all of a
sudden much better,
then it's just a
temporary problem.
But still remember that the
temporary problem may become
an insurmountable hurdle,
because in real life,
you can't force people
to use it for two days
until they have gotten better.
So often people just
give up on something.
I mean, it depends on
what it is whether or not
people will stick through it.
But that's why you need to
learn these kind of assistance
mechanisms that help people--
if you move something
around in an interface,
in the old place,
leave a little marker
behind for a long time
to teach people where it moved.
Things like that.
So you need to help
people overcome that
as much as you can.
Because it is real.
AUDIENCE: I'm concerned
I'm kind of reiterating
the last question.
I've noticed a bit of a
trend-- people back-porting
mobile interface
paradigms to the desktop,
kind of like what Apple
did with scrolling.
JAKOB NIELSON: Yeah, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Do you think that's
a good move in the long term
for the sake of kind of
normalizing those things?
Especially for-- my kids think
in terms of touch devices,
for example.
Will that make more
sense to them inevitably?
Is it worthwhile?
Or is it just arbitrary?
JAKOB NIELSON: Well, I mean,
first of all, part of it
is arbitrary, like the example
I showed with the pine cone.
That's just a completely
arbitrary symbol.
But if that is a
symbol people know,
then take advantage of
that and then use it.
And It could be the same here.
If people have a lot of
experience with, let's say,
mobile interaction
paradigms, then
that could be your first
gold mine-- the first thing
that you go to mine or pick
from when you're coming up
with ideas for a new design.
I mean, definitely leverage
what people already know.
That said, one of the points
I made in my presentation
was that there are differences
between the devices.
And one of the big differences
is that on a desktop computer
you have a much larger screen,
you have a more accurate
pointing device, and so forth.
So I don't actually
think that we really
should move to having only touch
interaction on the desktop,
because I think we
can do much more.
And also these
bigger gestures you
have to do on a
really big screen also
are more tiring and
so forth as well.
So I don't think we
should make it the same.
But I think we
should try-- I mean,
consistency is always good.
It's good for its own sake.
This is why design is a little
bit more challenging than just
saying oh, [SNAP]
this is how we do it.
Because you have kind of
contrasting trends there.
PRESENTER: All right.
So let's go to two
more questions.
And I'm going to ask mine first,
and then we'll end with yours.
This question, I think
it's interesting,
because it's from the book.
And I'm interested
in the relationship
between client apps on
mobile devices and web apps--
or interaction with
web-based products--
and how you see that
playing out over time.
JAKOB NIELSON: Right.
Well, I mean, over time
is a little bit different.
But I think what we know now
is that the native apps are
definitely superior, just
because of what I was saying,
that you optimize to the device.
And the more impoverished the
device is, the more important
it is that you optimize
as much as possible.
And that's what the
native app will do.
And that said, I think
that over time we
will expect that the mobile
devices gets more powerful,
the mobile bandwidth gets
speedier, and so forth.
And also the web tool kits and
whatever get better as well.
And so I would actually expect
that this distinction will
probably narrow
and not be as big.
And in five years
from now, it may well
be that a well-designed
mobile website will
be just as good or
better than a native app.
So it may not be
something that one
would want to invest in
for the true long term.
But I think for the short
term, I would recommend.
Well, if it's something
that's a big, important thing,
I would recommend
doing a native app.
And if it's a small
scale thing that's
going to have five users,
then just do the website.
But right now, I would say
the app is still better.
PRESENTER: And
our last question.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Since you have the future
in the title of your speech,
so I wonder what you
think about the future
of the gesture-controlled input,
or something like Xbox Kinect?
How do you think?
Do you think that's the
future of the interface?
JAKOB NIELSON: That's a
great, great question.
I just don't think
it's the future.
I'd say I had futures-- in
plural-- in my title slide.
Because I do think that it's
going to be more diversified.
And I think as a
lot of environments
were having-- well, having
your body be the input device,
having the world become the
computational environment.
I think there's a lot
to be said for that.
At the same time, I don't think
that's the only thing-- even
the optimal thing-- for a lot
of the tasks we will want to do.
So I think there's a
lot to be said still
for having as big a
screen as possible.
I don't know what's
the biggest screen.
I have never yet seen
the truly biggest screen.
But maybe certainly the size of
an old fashioned big newspaper
is probably the biggest
screen we would want to have.
But about that size, at
least 300 DPI resolution
and so forth.
So a millions of
pixels type of screen.
I think there's a lot of value
in that for a lot of the tasks
people want to do.
So I think both types of
interfaces will be there.
Gestures have several downsides.
They are less precise, and
therefore, certainly, they
have less of that
persistence-- whereas something
that's a visual interface.
And there's a reason why
all these icons and stuff
have lived for so long.
It's because they have a lot of
usability and inherent benefits
by being steady on the
screen-- you can see them,
you can remember them,
they tell you what to do,
what to click on.
Whereas with a gesture, I
got to make up the gesture,
I got to remember the
gesture, and so forth.
So you probably have a
smaller vocabulary there.
There are a fewer number of
fancy gestures you could--
I mean, we know even
now from tablets
that any advanced
gesture you will not
see if you're going to
study with normal users,
because they don't
do advanced gestures.
They only do, like, tap and
slide and very simple things.
PRESENTER: All right.
Thank you all for
joining us today,
and please join me in
thanking Jakob Nielson.